starting off this hours Paul in New
Jersey hey Paul welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show what is up David it's good
to be here good to have you sir how can
we help so I got a question uh my wife
says I'm too prideful and it's not a
good sign do I just
[Laughter]
maybe not but let me let me run through
the numbers right so we have I try to
stick to a budget
she doesn't stick to the budget we make
about 5,000 per month and she blows her
and onboard knows whatever what is her
name
what do you mean her end so she makes
about 2,000 per month so you don't do a
budget together that you both decide on
what's going to happen to the household
income
no I'm saying 5,000 is what comes in per
month and both of you decide what's
gonna happen to that how does she have
an end oh I see I guess the problem is I
feel like I'm responsible of paying all
the bills and now when things get behind
payment and things end up showing up
late and cable get cut off once in a
while I'm the one that getting hated for
it and disappointed and I don't really
think that necessary
okay well the cable shouldn't be cut off
you should either cut it off and not
have it or if you can't afford it or it
should be in the budget and be paid on
time and so here's the way it should
work the two of you put all the money
every single freaking dime that both of
you make in one pile that is called
our money for our goals then we sit down
at the kitchen table and give every one
of those dollars an assignment and then
we execute on that plan that we both
have agreed on pinky swear and spit
shake it's a contract and so out of that
you would plan and say
I you know this is my income this is
your income so this the total of that is
our income and the first thing we're
going to do is buy food and here's our
food budget
the next thing we're going to buy is
lights and water and cable and here's
that budget here's what that's going to
cost this coming month and then here's
the house payment this coming month and
then here's and then here's and then
here's and everything's written down to
where every dollar that we as a couple
have made is given an assignment and we
are but we both have a vote on where
that money is going to go and how it's
going to be spent and we are both in
agreement that this is how we are gonna
spend our money there's no end her end
your end there's no you're supposed to
pay all the bills and she's not we both
work we both have a pile of money I mean
we have a pile of money as a couple for
better for worse for richer for poorer
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
the old-fashioned marriage vows say if
you went at it that way I think all of
what you're describing would disappear
wouldn't it it sounds like it because
you would never plan to not pay the
cable bill well your money we try to
stretch every dollar so no I mean no no
no no you would have a written plan
where every one of your dollars of
income is gonna go on paper on purpose
or in the every dollar app that both you
and your wife has agreed to meaning
there is no money to spend anywhere
except what we've agreed to you don't
have any side deals and so we spend
exactly what we both agreed to and we
both have a vote
you would never set out with both of you
sitting at the kitchen table looking at
all of your income and intentionally get
the cable cut off well she says I'm
living above our means we're living a
boy and another thing I said no I'm
listening okay would you be living above
your means if you did what I told you to
do just now I think there's one problem
I think we probably have over
stretched our money as far as we can so
when you laid out that budget you think
you'd run out of money if you sat down
and plan the month of December on paper
you're saying you don't you don't think
you have enough income to cover your
bills I think it's uh some some things
are gonna have to get like some things
are gonna have to get deadly so you
don't have enough income in the month of
December to pay December's bills I mean
we could say that I mean we could get
some a thing man do you or not so what
do you make what's your take home pay
uh it's luckily because I'm an uber
driver and of course that's not how it's
supposed to be I wish the world could be
better but my book my incomes more
around like twenty-two hundred per month
okay what does she bring home she brings
home a steady 2000 okay so we have
$4,200 how much is your rent rent is
about two thousand there's the problem
your rent is fifty percent of your
income there's no possible way you can
make it on that the income either goes
up or you have to move why get moving I
can't think I can help you sir
I appreciate you calling in